[MUSIC]
Welcome, my name is Will Torres.
I'm one of the admission officers here at
the Stanford Graduate School of Business.
I'm so excited that you're here with us
today talking about and preparing for
a journey into the world of technology and
product management.
We're here to really talk
about how to use that MBA and
the GSB experience specifically if you're
thinking about launching into a career in
the technology or
product management space.
And so to get us oriented
to our conversation today,
we're going to do a brief overview,
especially about what some of
the career outcomes look like post MBA.
We are going to get to know our
panelists and then from there,
I'll have a few questions and we're
really going to open it up from there.
The Q&A box is again,
going to be where you're going to
be able to ask your questions.
If there is a question that you like, I
encourage you to use that thumbs up button
that's going to up-vote that question and
bring it to the top of the list.
You'll also see a quick survey going on
right now about when you're thinking about
applying.
This is also helpful for us as we start to
think about what tips, best practices and
words of wisdom we might be
able to share with you today.
So, as part of that overview, so
when you come to Stanford GSB,
the world really does become your oyster.
There is a career management center
who works with all of our students.
About a third of students get
opportunities through there.
Another third from alumni,
as well as our fellow classmates.
So there is no shortage of places for
folks to find both full time as well
as internship opportunities
during your time and beyond.
About 91% of the class of 2020 had job
offers within three months of graduation.
And people had this sense of confidence
of being able to find something that they
were really interested.
And that was meaningful for them.
I know I've had a number of conversations
about folks who said, you know what,
I have this job offer.
And I know there's something
better out there for me.
Part of the Stanford experience was
helping them build that confidence to know
that yes, something was out there and
yes, they will find it.
And kind of long story short, they did.
About 71% of folks who come to Stanford
made some kind of pivot whether it's
geography, industry, function.
And this is a question I often get,
if you write something in your application
now, we don't hold you to that.
So if you're interested in tech but you
end up in consulting, that's wonderful.
Coming to business school is
about expanding your horizons and
see what else is out there.
If something speaks to you.
If you want to explore that world and
take that step,
we are here to help you make that happen.
And now to give a little bit more
light to this process specifically,
let's go ahead and meet our panelists.
So Tomer, could you please tell us
a little bit about what you're doing now,
and did you know you wanted to go into
like the tech product space coming into
the GSB?
>> That's a great introduction.
Thanks also.
Hi everyone.
My name is Tomer Schwartz.
I'm part of the class of
2018 from here at the GSB.
I am currently working as
a product manager, product lead at
a tech called startup, a series B startup
in San Francisco called Rippling.
To your question on whether or
not I knew I wanted to be in the tech job.
It's a good question,
I think coming into the GSB.
I did, I had worked in technology before.
I had actually worked in
product management for
about six months prior to the GSB.
So, I would say it was more of an educated
hypothesis than like a firm belief.
[LAUGH] But definitely,
I had a bit of a taste of it before.
Prior to product management, I had done
stuff around implementation of customers.
And so I had seen different
parts of what it would be like
to work at mostly enterprise
B2B tech companies.
And so heading into GSB I knew something
that I wanted to poke a little bit
further on, and see if that was going to
be the right thing post graduation.
And I think so far, it has seen that
way for years after graduation.
>> Did you do much exploring
during your time at the GSB?
>> Yeah, I did a bit of exploring.
My undergraduate major
was in biochemistry and
so, I have always had a bit
of an edge to see whether or
not life sciences would be a place
where I could angle my way.
And so
that was a few hypothesis coming in.
And while I worked for my first years
out of undergrad at a tech firm
focused on pharmaceutical companies.
I spent a bit of time during
my first year at the GSB.
I actually did like a part-time
internship during the winter at a company
working with actually mRNA which
since COVID has become very hot.
[LAUGH] It was less hot at the time.
And it was a good hands on experience,
seeing I did some like strategy and
did ops for them.
And ultimately I ended up deciding
to kind of stick with tech.
Though for my summer internships,
my first year I did pursue
sort of both in a parallel track but
ended up going more angling towards tech.
I would say relatively quickly,
I think by March,
in my first year I become pretty confident
that that was going to be the likely route
at least immediately post graduation.
>> Yeah.
For that winter term internship,
was that part of a program or
was that something that you
kind of pursued independently?
Like how did you go about that?
>> Yeah, it's a good question.
So I would say,
it ended up being a little bit of both.
I'm trying to remember
where I found out about it.
I believe it had been posted by either
one of my classmates through a friend of
a friend, or it was on like the careers
to the career website sort of like
routinely update stuff.
And it's the stuff that they update
is not only for full time or
official internship stuff,
some of it is a little bit more ad-hoc.
So it was a resource that I used pretty
extensively throughout my time to kind of
see like, hey, every few days like,
is there something interesting?
It's a fairly like low cost
effort to hop on the website and
see if there's interesting stuff.
Of course, I'd say, pursuing a part
time internship during school
is the major like, decision just because
of all the different things vying for
your time when you're at the GSB,
which are awesome.
And you normally have to trade stuff off,
you can't do everything
despite our desire to.
So I think I, now that I think of it,
I probably found out about
it from that career website.
>> And you already like started to
go into what I was about to ask you.
How did you balance both that
internship plus like winter quarter of
your MBA one year?
Didn't you still have like some
of your core requirements?
>> Yeah.
So I think, winter quarter freshman year,
MBA one year is known
as like one of the more brutal
academic quarters because you're,
usually finances the kind of
killer class in that set.
And yeah, it was not a,
I think the internship ended up
devoting about ten to 12 hours a week.
So it wasn't crazy but again,
it was up in San Francisco.
So I was taking, Wednesdays, we normally
like don't have classes at the GSB.
So it was a good opportunity to head up.
To the city and do mostly a full day in
the office during that I would usually do
kind of half a day either on Fridays or
on Mondays with whatever or without.
It was not easy and there's a lot of,
I would say jealousy
seeing what other classmates of
mine were doing at the time.
But I felt like it was still worth
investigating especially prior
to my internship maybe kind of
full time internship first year.
So because I want to say, okay, this seems
like the right route, it doesn't seem like
the right route, in this case it
didn't seem like the right route.
So I think it was time well spent.
Yeah, and then kind of sticking
on this theme of internships.
So, you did two internships in the summer
between your MBA one and MBA two year?
No, no, so I did that one in the winter.
I didn't do what we call like a GSD.
I just did one, I did a 12 week
internship at PayPal between my first and
second years.
Okay, and then there's a question here
about how early does recruiting start for
project management internships
at some of the firms.
Do you have any insight
there because- Yeah, so
it really depends how big of a company
you're looking to intern at.
So the general trend that you'll
see is that the large companies
that have very organized,
headcount modeling and
recruiting processes are able to
kick off that process actually,
towards the end of November you
start chit chatting with them and
seeing what's out there.
And then interviews will actually begin
around the middle of January when you
return from winter break
heading into February.
That said, I see the majority of people
that are looking to go into tech
end up getting their internships
in the spring quarter,
which is between April and in June.
And that is usually smaller companies, but
even some of the larger
companies kind of come from
through with opportunities
later on in the year.
I think one thing that's helpful and
coming in is sort of having
a hypothesis of whether or not,
a large company is of interest,
it's a small company is of interest.
Both, because that'll sort of define
the timeline that you end up taking.
Yeah, and so like were recruiters
coming to campus where you,
did you do some initial reach out or how
did you make some of these connections or
to learn about the opportunities?
Yeah, it's a great question.
So, I started with, again,
the lowest friction approach,
which is the career website.
So that was, again, the easiest place to
access, I think it was after the six week.
I can't even remember what it's called.
But there's a bit of a moratorium on
career stuff during the first six weeks,
which is actually great to let people
settle into academics on campus for
your MBA one year.
And then everything sort of opens up.
And so I recall,
checking out the career website a bit.
And then, starting to develop my own list.
There are a bunch of other resources
if you're more focused on.
Smaller companies if you're
focused on specific niches within
the tech sector, tech can stand for
a lot of different things.
And then obviously you start
kind of poking at alumni and
the alumni directory seeing what kind of
random emails come through from classmate,
who used to work at these companies.
You start doing a lot, a lot of coffee
chats with MBA twos who're usually
really like nice and
generous with their time.
So, it's a whole host of things and that's
kind of what I was getting out with,
time is at a premium for
everything at the GSB.
And so being a little bit thrifty with
how you spend it, is really critical.
Yeah, and then as you're thinking about,
so your journey and
then other friends or folks that you know
who have gone into the tech space or
the product management space.
There's a question here about, do you have
to have a background in product management
to get an internship or a job after or
kind of, how does that look like?
That's a good question.
I think it's a pretty common question
that a lot of my classmates came in with
as well.
And definitely they are concerned because
a lot of people come in with a sort of
an HR hypothesis saying this
product thing sounds interesting.
I've done a bit of research,
but can I get in?
I definitely have a lot of classmates who
did not have product experience who were
able to get into product.
The way that I usually look at it,
with product is sort of what
strengths you can play on.
And prior experience and background is
a facet but definitely not the only facet.
So other sort of pillars to think
about when you're considering this
sort of career would be one like I
think attention to detail is critical.
I think the ability to
think strategically,
especially as future MBA graduates,
is a huge one to play up.
And that's something that companies will
really be looking for, being analytical.
So a lot of folks that have
consulting experience or
finance experience can sort of leverage
that and play that up in their interview.
Another critical facet that
people are looking for
when it relates to product,
is interpersonal skills.
Product managers end up being
in the middle of a whole bunch
of different functions at their company.
And for better or worse, your key to
success is being able to communicate
with your other team members who
are not product managers and
sort of speaking their languages.
So, some of the, what we call soft skills,
that we focus on a lot at the GSB
end up really helping with that.
So I would say as far as recruiting goes,
you have to strategically understand
what company you're interviewing on.
Who you're talking to, and
what strengths you can play up.
It won't be the same sort of script or
story that you can tell it every
company it really will depend on how
you can convince that you have
the right skill set to bring to them.
And given the specific team
that you're interviewing at,
the specific industry
that the company is at,
but you definitely will have both from
your PGSB experience, MGSB experience,
a bunch of tools in your toolkit to
talk about during the interview process.
Even if you don't have more classic
like I was a PM prior to the GSB.
Perfect segue.
Let's talk about some of these tools.
I know on one side there
are some of the hard skills and
then you mentioned some of
the softer skills interpersonal
kind of elements that are so
critical to your work.
Can you tell me a little
bit about any classes?
Let's start with the soft skill side,
the interpersonal,
anything that stood out to you and why.
Of course, I mean, I think for the very,
we joke about this as GSB graduates,
but the class that you will
often hear about is colloquially
called touchy feely or
interpersonal dynamics.
And I think for
me it was a class that I heard about
coming free prior to coming to the GSB.
And it definitely did not disappoint.
[LAUGH] And it's really interesting
experiential class where you spend
the majority of your time rather than,
like in a lecture setting,
you end up spending it with
what's called a tea group which
is a group of you plus 11 of your
classmates plus the facilitator.
And you go through a bunch of, call it,
interpersonal journey [LAUGH] for
a quarter and
that was really critical, I think,
for understanding how
other people perceive you.
How different things that you end
up saying really touch other people
even if you don't necessarily mean them.
And then kind of if you want to think
about it more about how do I get
my job done?
It's also how you can influence people.
Ultimately, a lot of this stuff is about,
especially when it comes to product,
is around influence.
How can you influence people to believe
in the the problems that you're
trying to prioritize as a product manager?
And so that class touchy-feely,
your interpersonal dynamics,
is definitely a critical one, I think.
There are a few other classes that I think
are mentioned less often that are around
soft skills.
So for example,
one is called acting with power which is
a really fun one, where you literally act.
[LAUGH] It is a very real acting, which
for me was not a point of comfort acting,
not something I have background in, but
it was a really fun unique experience
that you can only achieve in school.
I think it's very difficult to
replicate elsewhere in the workplace.
And we actually would have scripts
slash academic materials explaining
how different tactics cause people
to perceive us in different ways.
And it sounds very ego maniacal but
it can go a long way when
you're in different sort of
situations in the workplace.
So those are some of the softer ones,
will do,
I'm going to transition to
some more tangible things.
>> No,
I actually have a couple more questions.
So this is like a fascinating track
of conversation talking about how
you show up in a space and
how you exert influence.
There are a couple questions here about,
and I'm sure this is going to be
a recurring question that comes
up over our conversation.
But from either touchy-feely,
acting with power or
any of the other classes,
maybe even leadership labs.
Have there been any instances where you've
been implementing some of the things
you've learned in there, and
how has that like affected the way
that you operate in the working place?
>> All the time.
I mean, especially for, I always joke for
better words, in product,
I have not had a moment where I could
be alone in a room just doing stuff,
which means that everything
is interpersonal, right?
Everything is about how people
are reacting to the ideas
that I'm bringing forth, how I'm reacting
to their input and collaboration.
And so for me a few of the examples that
I think about are we learn about when
to use emotion, for example, and how
to express different levels of emotion.
And how someone can be even keeled for
the majority of their time,
as when you know them all of a sudden
when they engage in extreme emotion,
you really pay attention to that.
Because it's so different,
then they're standard status quo, and so
that's a tactic that I've used a few times
at work to really get a point across.
It's not something that I
would choose to abuse but
it's one that I remember
when I went through it,
it was a kind of like an aha
finding moment from touchy-feely.
People gave me feedback that said,
I was really surprised,
when you act that way,
it really made me pay attention.
And it was not something that I
did on purpose in touchy-feely
because it happened to be a very
involuntary reaction to something
that happened there but
was a really powerful learning.
And then the other one is around how to,
I've already talked about,
is around how to show,
kind of like use vulnerability to get
people to understand you better and
to trust you.
So I think that was one of, again,
a huge lesson from these classes around.
I think that the kind of,
I call it cheap learning,
is to never show cracks in the armor,
right?
To never waver from a strong determined
person who knows what they're doing.
But actually there are many times where
showing just a little bit of vulnerability
or a lot of vulnerability if it's with the
right audience or the right people who,
that's what it takes to get them on
board can be incredibly powerful.
The tricky thing is that it doesn't
work on everyone and it doesn't work at
the right time, which is [LAUGH] one of
the frustrating learnings from the class.
It's not a perfect playbook.
There's a lot of kind of try and learn and
try and learn but these have definitely
been important things for me as I've
gone back into the world the last
three years to get my points across and
be a successful product manager.
>> Yeah, I love how that comes back
to what you're talking about earlier
about getting the tools
you need to succeed.
And it's like, here's the tool and
then in that, try and iterate and
kind of workshopping it over
the course of your career.
Just like continuing to sharpen and
kind of fine tune those tools to
the settings that you need it for.
>> There's a lot of fine tuning.
[LAUGH] Sometimes you miss a little bit,
but there's a lot of fine tuning.
>> Yeah, that's part of the process too,
how do we embrace, quote unquote,
failure as opportunities to learn growth
mindset, that spirit of feedback.
[LAUGH] Feedback is a gift.
>> Absolutely, yeah, feedback is a gift is
something that you hear a lot at the GSB,
and I think is something that can be
not fun to take both at the GSB and
in the real world, but
it is a really powerful takeaway.
And I think something that I
still sort of, Wil as you said,
workshop and tinker with and
decide how to really take in.
And it is helpful to not be defensive
about feedback that comes in, and
that was a big, for me personally, it's
like a big learning during my time here.
>> Yeah, I mean,
it's a learning that I'm still trying
to process even in the working world.
[LAUGH] It's just like I feel something.
Let's unpack that.
[LAUGH]
>> Exactly.
>> Let's switch over to the hard skills.
I know we talked a lot about
the personal development,
how you show up in a space,
how you influence.
What are also like some of
the technical hard skills that you find
are helpful in your job?
Kind of whether it's in product itself, or
just kind of in the tech world writ large.
because I know there are also
some questions here about,
okay, what are other opportunities in the
world of tech beyond product management?
>> Yeah, definitely,
a few classes that come to mind.
For me the areas that were,
so I was a biochem major, so
for me, academically,
a lot of this stuff was new.
So there were a few marketing classes,
for example, that I found to be helpful.
So one that comes to mind is
a class called consumer behavior.
We really focused on,
I wouldn't call them tricks but
actual tactics and
strategies to get consumers to better,
Go towards your desired outcome,
let's put it that way.
And so, I think that one in particular is
important if you're thinking about going
to a B2C company, where your main user
will be a consumer but it's still helpful.
Even for me at a company like Rippling
where I work today that is B2B,
where most of my customers
are business customers, but
it's small businesses, so
they tend to act like consumers.
And so, when they think about things like
visual design and how we talk to them,
I definitely think of some
lessons from that class.
Honestly, my intro to marketing class
around things like segmentation,
and positioning, and targeting,
was really critical,
I didn't have any background in that.
I definitely came from
the mindset that marketing was
some voodoo art that didn't have
a lot of actual discipline to it.
And so, that has been really helpful and
thinking about how you, like for me,
at least as a product manager,
how I focus on my customers,
how I segment them,
who my target customer is.
How I can make sure that when I'm building
something or I'm prioritizing something,
I'm really focused on what I've
refined as the target segment.
And not just trying to peanut
butter it to an entire market,
because that's impossible to solve,
and so that has been very important.
And then there's a lot of, I had never
taken an accounting class to be honest.
And actually some people will say,
accounting is boring, it's this and that.
I think it's a really critical foundation
for anyone who's going to end up being
a leader in business, even if you're
not going to be an accountant, and
I don't think anyone in my class really
went deep into specializing in accounting.
But it's a really critical core
skill to understand profit and
loss statement, and cash flows,
and things of that nature.
It makes you much more able to talk
when you're in a room with other folks,
maybe finance folks that are trying
to make decisions around
how to allocate head count to your team.
And you're like,
I want to go toe-to-toe with you and
make sure that I get the proper
head count that I need.
You're able to do that a lot more
than someone who's just like,
I'm only a product manager and
just put the heads on my team of people.
So actually having a detailed
numbers-based conversation is incredibly
helpful.
And then, lastly, I mean, some other
classes that were very specific, not very
specific, but ended up really helping
in product, so one is Startup Garage.
As you know, Startup Garage
sort of employs design thinking
to how you refine a problem, and then
eventually think through a hypothesis.
And point of view statement in a solution
which even though Startup Garage sort of
sounds like something that you would do if
you want to go only into entrepreneurship.
That's actually not quite correct,
the frameworks that are taught there,
I use pretty routinely in product,
because we really try in product
to think about agile development and
hypothesis-based development.
And so, this type of a class really forces
you to go through the rigor of refining
a problem, asking a bajillion questions,
lead the customer discovery before
you ever think about a solution.
And so, that one, I actually don't
think was properly advertised.
I remember when going through it,
as this will help you if you
want to go into product.
They were sort of like, hey,
people that are thinking about
entrepreneurship go here, and looking
back on it, that one was really helpful.
The last one that I talked about is called
aligning startups with their market,
which actually don't know if it's still
being offered, but was really helpful.
And again, even though aligning startups
with their markets sounds like it's really
focused on entrepreneurship.
It can be leveraged for, basically,
any new product initiative even if it's
at a larger company in my opinion.
And so, again, really focused on
customer discovery and how you pivot,
how you judge when you may have
reached product market fit,
how you think about scaling.
So, those are a few of the classes that
come to mind, there are, obviously,
a bunch of other ones that I
found to be helpful throughout.
>> Yeah,
I love all of the translatable learnings,
the frameworks and not just
entrepreneurship as a career path, but
also as a way of thinking that is
applicable to so many different spaces.
>> Exactly.
>> So you've been at a large firm,
you've been at a small firm,
you've seen a breadth of different kind
of roles that someone can go into tech,
especially thinking about the MBA and
the skill sets that you develop.
What are some other roles within
the tech world that you've seen some
of your classmates go into?
>> Yeah, so
there are a bunch of different roles.
So one of the more common ones that I've
seen is business ops, which is depending
on the company, it's sort of an internal
consultant at a tech company.
[LAUGH] A second one would be
Product Marketing Management,
PMM, very, very common to go into.
And then there's sort of a whole host
of other more refined things at smaller
companies or larger companies
that call them different stuff.
So, they run the gamut, right?
You can be on the non-development
side of the house and
still definitely be in the tech world
having come from an MBA, right?
You can deploy more strategic skills
purely or you can be on the product side,
so I've seen people go
into a variety of roles.
In my opinion, that's one of
the beauties of kind of a general
management MBA,
purposefully makes you very valuable.
One of the frustrating things about it
could be that it doesn't set you on
a super narrow path.
So, I think that's a really
important consideration for
folks who are thinking about a full-time
general management MBA to know
it's sort of opens up a lot of doors.
But it will force you to
do a lot of research and
testing to see which of the many
opportunities are right for you.
>> Yeah, and then pivoting, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Post-graduation,
that's probably not going to be your
career for the rest of your life.
>> 100%.
>> And so
how do you set up for
the skills to thrive elsewhere?
because you've already pivoted,
right, from large to small.
>> That's right, yeah, and I think for me,
actually one of the main
sort of the last push for
me to end up actually applying for an MBA,
was because I had gotten to point at.
So I worked at a company called Zenefits
prior to the GSB, and I had been there for
a year, I had done some other
stuff in a different company.
But I had been there for a year,
I felt like I was doing really well,
folks really appreciating my work.
And I decided that I wanted to switch
to a different team internally,
actually wanted to switch from
implementation to product marketing.
And so, I went through a pretty
disorganized internal process,
as a small company,
there's no official process.
I spoke with the person who
was running that team, and
she ended up giving me a little
case exercise, I solved.
And she's like, you're great,
we'd love to have you join.
And eventually what happened was, and so
I was like, that's amazing, I'm so excited
about this new opportunity, because
I was tired of where I was working.
I wanted to learn new skills,
and they ended up for
a certain amount of time getting.
Blocked, and the thing that they told me
was you're doing well, where you are.
You're doing very well where you are,
we need you here.
And for me personally, I was at a prayer
I was like, no, I want to do this.
And that was actually the thing that
prompted me to apply for an MBA.
I ended up seeing an MBA as a way to make
sure that my career was future proof.
It does not necessarily mean you're like
super successful day one high flying.
But it does give you the skills
to have a really fascinating and
dynamic career,
in my opinion, for decades.
It gives you the general skills to be able
to pivot and not pigeonhole yourself.
And so for me, with the point
that I was there I was like, no,
I don't want to be told that this
is the appropriate path for you.
Like I want to set out on my own path.
But i want to make sure I have
kind of the two kit to derive.
And so for me like that MBA
experience I was part of that.
>> Yeah, that's ow-full I know i get
to ask all the type of people like.
How do you know its the right time or
even like?
I don't know if I need
an MBA to be successful or
thrive in in X, Y or Z field.
So like, why go?
And so even again.
>> I think it's a super good question.
>> Yeah, so for me,
I thought about it as a long game.
I think it's a really,
it's a really good question, right?
Like, for a lot of folks, they're like,
I'm kicking butt at my
current place like I'm good.
I don't need an out and, thinking
back to a lot of my classmates like,
that's where they were,
they were doing incredibly well.
And they still decided to take that
time in the way that I well it's funny.
When I was applying, I went actually
to a GSB admission session.
And the director of admissions at
the time Derek started said this
thing which again,
you kind of you take with a grain of salt.
Because of course he's
trying to recruit people.
But he said, it's never going to
be truly feel comfortable and
never truly going to
feel like the right time.
The goal it's always going to be
a bit of an uncomfortable decision.
And if it is uncomfortable,
a slightly uncomfortable decision
it's probably the right time.
And for some reason that actually
really resonated with me.
It's like, when if you wait until
the point where you feel like you've
stagnated in your career and
then you need it.
You probably waited just
a little bit too long,
which I get is that it's
a very uncomfortable feeling.
Obviously an MBA is not the right
thing for everyone at all.
That I find it hard to believe that
you'll be at a point where you're like,
this is the perfect point for
me to go now, right?
Like, there's always a reason.
Why not?
There's always a reason to go elsewhere.
So you really have to ask yourself, like.
Why would I go?
Wat's the value that I would get?
What am i trading off?
And have a really serious
conversation with yourself.
And your stakeholders around in
your life around like when I put
everything down on a paper.
Or my mental checklist, or
however you make decisions, is this right?
But I don't, it'll never be like a binary
obvious decision, that was the right time.
That was the right school I think it's
difficult to get to that sort of clarity,
at least for me.
>> Yeah, so let's sit down with your
younger self and have that conversation.
I didn't, you probably didn't think you're
going to be having this conversation.
Say that this is a question from Danny
about, like, what was the value add for
you after six months?
So now that you're thinking like,
younger you.
You from a pre-MBA.
Where you're putting that decision,
how am I going to think about its worth,
to you today, six months or
just afterwards.
How would you articulate that to
your younger self to help them come
to a decision?
>> Yeah, it's a good question.
I think the way that I look at it now,
it kind of, it goes back to that.
At least for me,
I had always seen my MBA as a long-term
investment in my future self.
So it was not something that I expected
that the day after graduation would be.
My gosh, I turned the page and
like everything is different.
And it's one of those things, at least for
me where I see the lessons in like,
small bits throughout my day like
thinking back to the last three years.
That consistently throughout
the last three years.
And I anticipate that I will keep
seeing that as time goes on.
And so a part of it definitely like,
it did help me get to
the job at a larger company.
That I was interested in
pursuing right after the GSB.
So that's kind of like a very
tangible thing that it did.
But I think more importantly,
what it enabled me to do is to have that
flexibility to be able to be in
a variety of different situations.
That I you it's hard to anticipate
being in me like I did sort of going
through a laboratory [LAUGH] that
helped me prepare me for that.
Or I did have a classmate
who worked in that industry.
Or I did have like this really rich
conversation with someone about this
particular problem that they had and
now I'm going through it.
Or I need to form a partnership for
work and hey,
this other GSB is on the other side.
So like, you sort of see the value
in like a variety of different ways,
ways throughout.
>> Nice, and then there's a question here.
So, actually multiple
questions around like.
Hey, I'm going to distill it and this is
these are questions from Ryan and Addy and
Jinzhou, about Kinsale about.
We talked a little bit about classes,
but for
folks who are like thinking
about pivoting or exploring.
What are some opportunities and
resources that can help you get at least
a little bit of expert like
experience in that world?
And kind of get your feet wet?
>> I assume that they're asking while
at the GSB because obviously like some
people.
So I think it was,
I can think of a few things.
Some of my classmates, for example,
decided to take classes what
we call across the street.
Which is outside of the GSB
at other Stanford classes.
So some people decided to take classes
at the design school for example.
Send people to classes in
the computer science department.
God bless them.
There are a whole bunch of things that
that being at a school like Stanford
allows you to do.
So that's one.
I think the second thing is doing
a part time during the year internship.
Which again is a sacrifice and
a trade off.
But part of being in product
is all about trade offs.
And to practice that in real life.
So I think that's incredibly helpful.
I think growing to really like
tapping into the alumni network is
critical from day one.
And it's a lot of work like, networking.
Some people love networking,
other people despise networking.
But no matter how you look at it,
it's incredibly time consuming.
I think it's rewarding and fun, but
like it's really time consuming.
So being able to spend a bunch of
your time, having conversations with
people in different industries,
at different companies sizes.
Because one of the beauties and
frustrating things about product is
that when you ask people
what a product manager does.
It, the answer will range from A to Z,
especially if you ask people
at different companies.
And so it's actually really important
to be able to do the research,
to understand like.
Okay, is this someone
who's doing more strategy?
Are they spending 80% of their time
with just engineering and design?
Are they more on the go to market side?
And how does that fit my strengths and
my desires and
how can I use that to refine
my career search better so
that I can achieve both
my desired outcomes but
what I'm capable of doing
given my prior background.
So I would do a combo of those, right,
like talk to alumni outside of classes,
talk to a bunch of your classmates.
A lot of my classmates actually sort
of we joke at the GC that everyone
has a side hustles.
So a lot of people tried to start
even outside of startup garage,
they have little things that they were
trying out and hey, that's the way
to both have real world experience,
but also to beef up your resume a bit.
So, and the other thing that folks did,
especially when they were trying to
transition is they did either incredibly
low paid or unpaid internships which,
at smaller companies to at least get
a sense of what product would be like.
We had no experience and
you can do that while you're in school.
It's not as big of a sacrifice as
obviously doing something unpaid
post graduation, which is a really
big decision and investment.
>> Yeah, I'm going to go back to
something you said a little bit earlier
about spending a lot of time and
energy in networking and
how some people thrive in it and
others it's a little bit more effort.
Having gone through that process yourself
and kind of lessons learned along the way.
For those of us who find it a little
bit more draining, any tips or
inspiration or words of encouragement
that you have to help us think about,
what is networking, how can we apply
it especially in the tech space?
>> I would think about it.
Some people approach networking as like,
so
I would say quality is
better than quantity, right?
So, if you're thinking about
networking as like, if I have 50,
5-0 conversations and they're each,
boom, boom, boom, boom,
boom, kind of 15 minutes very focused,
I'm sure I'll get something out of them.
I mean, yeah, you might but
it sounds really painful.
You have to be a very particular
sort of person to do that.
I would focus on quality so
spending more time doing more research,
but having less conversations
actually would be my advice for
the majority of the time to
invest in a conversation,
really go deep with someone
who's a proper fit.
But then obviously yeah,
part of it is sure it's a numbers game but
that I would more tailor
towards keep an eye,
have quick conversations with classmates.
Even if y'all aren't best friends or you
don't necessarily see the right path but
choose where you're investing the time.
Choose which alumni
you're reaching out to.
Don't run yourself dry.
I think networking will be a lot less
painful if you're having conversations
with with people that you truly find
to be valuable and interesting.
I don't think it'll be 100% of the time.
Sometimes it's like, yeah,
it's a bit of work and it's a grind.
But I think if most of the networking
that you do is stuff that you find to be
interesting, which will probably
mean just less conversations.
You're going to be, okay, that maybe took
me a little bit to click send on an email.
It took me a little bit to get out of
the house to go to Koopa in the middle of
campus even though I was like God,
I really don't want to do
the awkward coffee meetup.
But otherwise, I feel once you sit down
and have the conversation, it's really
rewarding, and I guess now in the world
of COVID it'll probably be via Zoom.
But you get my point.
>> Yeah, here's a question from Sofia,
that has a number of upvotes.
What surprised you about the PM role or
experience coming out of the GSB?
And we talked a little bit about, actually
a lot about how the GSB set you up for
success, but yeah, any surprises?
>> Yeah, I mean, so at least for me,
right, the role that I took after the GSB
was at PayPal, which is not massive
like Google, but it's quite large.
It was not a total shocker because again,
I interned there,
but what,
the just the sheer amount of time that I
spent sort of convincing
people of stuff rather than
solving a problem or
actually building things.
That was a bit of a surprise and
a bit of a disappointment and
I think it might have been a function of
the particular team that I went on, which
was more of a newer team at a big company,
which was really exciting for me actually.
But then I think looking back on it and
then that it was a lot of
trying to get people on board
with really unbaked ideas.
And so for me learning from that was okay,
I should try to, I get a lot of
energy out of seeing impact.
Which I don't think is a rare thing,
but at least for
me that has a very concrete,
positive reinforcing cycle.
And so that was one of the reasons
why I decided to go to my
current company to Ripling which is and
was a lot smaller, but
fast growing in it is much easier for
me to see the impact that my
work is doing technically in
the same role as a product manager.
Which is day in and
day out I'm able to ship little things and
or big things and
see how our customers are using them,
see the pleasure or
pain that they're giving to customers.
And for me, that's a huge, huge,
huge, positive reinforcement.
So I'm like, ooh, I want more of that.
I will work harder.
Whereas when I, at least for
me when I was at PayPal,
I just spent a ton of time
doing PowerPoint presentations,
[LAUGH] which I knew was
going to be a part of the role.
I did not anticipate that it would
consume that proportion of as
high of a proportion of my time as it did.
>> Yeah, it sounds like in any
presentation some of those soft skills,
interpersonal dynamics, learnings, acting
with power probably came in really handy.
>> Absolutely, yeah.
So yeah, so that was helpful,
I was able to navigate it well.
I just had gotten to a point where I
said okay, do I want to spend 80%?
Do I want to spend 20% of my time
kind of talking in between teams and
doing presentations or
do I want to spend 80% of my time?
And so at least for me that decision
to move to Ripling at least at this
very fine tuned stage in my career,
I was like, okay, I want to shift it.
I'm very realistic.
I understand that inner dynamics
at work are critical to succeed.
That's one of my learnings from the GSB.
But I would prefer to optimize for
less of my time being spent that way.
>> Yeah, and here's a question
from David that I really,
this is the first time
I've heard this question.
I really appreciate it because we talk
a lot about spirit of collaboration,
community.
But David wants to know what opportunities
are available for GSB students
interested in tech or product to connect
and or work on projects together?
We talked a lot about supporting each
other but on a more tactical side,
does it happen?
>> Yeah, that's a great, so
I mean, it definitely happened so
immediately when you ask that question
startup garage comes to mind, right?
That's a very Tangible way
to point out the way this
enterprise works is that you end up
forming teams of four to five people.
And you propose a high level problem
statement and you form these teams.
And so that's probably one of
the more concrete ways that the GSB
facilitates that.
That said,
there are a bunch of ad hoc ways that
people end up sort of collaborating.
There are things like career groups your
first year, where you get put together and
you have a facilitator from the CMC,
where you talk about this sort of stuff.
So I say that there's more
tactical hands on things.
And actually a lot of your classes
end up having group based projects,
which is [LAUGH] a double edged sword,
but a good learning.
So it'll sort of depend, right?
If I saw a bunch of folks from my class
who ended up either starting side
hustles and or real companies together
throughout their times at the GSB,
some of them are still
working on these companies.
And most of them were not start up garage.
It was like, hey I'm interested in this,
hey I'm interested in this.
Hey, we either have the same background or
we have complementary backgrounds,
let's try to work on this together.
Or what we joke about, the classic, try
to recruit a CS student to work with you.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] I saw a little bit of that
trying to happen, but
hopefully we can dispel those stereotypes.
I think GSBers can can do their own
work without recruiting poor CS
undergrads from [INAUDIBLE].
>> [LAUGH] But there is a lot of
interaction with other parts of
the campus, right?
>> Absolutely.
>> The different d.school courses.
>> I was going to say d.school courses,
bio design is a good one where
they end up bringing folks
from the engineering school.
And I think from the d.school and
from the GSB.
So that it kind of manifests
itself in a few different ways.
>> Yeah, there's a number of
interdisciplinary courses that
folks can take.
Or like you said, taking classes
from other departments on campus.
Great way to broaden your horizons both
intellectually and network-wise as well.
>> Absolutely.
>> All right, and so I'm going to be
selfish and take this last question.
I'm curious, we actually haven't talked
about the application much at all.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And even though you don't know and
you probably never will know why
you were admitted,
even though you are pretty awesome and
I loved spending this
last 55 minutes with you.
If you could give your younger self any
advice about the application process,
what would you tell yourself?
>> Yeah, so I mean, as you say, I think
one of the things that I joke about is,
after people get into the GSB,
they have all these fancy
theories about why they got in.
No one knows why they got in, unless you
tapped into the admissions office's files.
So I think for me, though,
what I would say is that,
what I would tell myself
looking back at the process,
is to try to enjoy it,
which sounds really tongue in cheek.
But it is a rare time,
at least for me, I was like,
heads down and working a full time job,
as is I assume the vast majority
of the folks on this call are,
or having a life and your personal life.
And I remember at the time when I
was applying, I was like, my gosh,
I have to think about what matters most to
me and why, you have got to be kidding me.
But it really forces you to have a unique
retrospective moment about yourself.
Why is it that you're looking to
invest two years of your life and
not an insignificant amount
of money in a program?
And so, it's a rare opportunity
to be able to be introspective,
where there's so many other things
happening around you in life.
And it can be if you do spend
the time really going deep and
thinking about okay,
why is this the right time for me?
What do I want to get out of this?
Why is it that I think it'll be helpful?
What do I want to do after?
It is an incredibly rewarding
introspective thing,
probably even if you don't get in.
[LAUGH] And I remember there's the GSB
grad from 2016 who was telling me
this when I was applying.
And I do remember being like, yeah,
easy for you to say because you got in,
and she was in MBA too at the time,
but I don't know, it's really true.
And the other thing that I would say is,
no one else can come up with
the right answer for you.
Because the combination of things
around why it's the right time,
what you want to do with it, why you?
You can't fake, that answer has to
come from investing the time and
thinking about all those questions.
And the story will inevitably
be uniquely for yourself.
So I would tell myself
to enjoy the process,
despite it being rightfully,
incredibly stressful.
[LAUGH]
>> Thank you so much for
your wisdom sharing your experiences.
Speaking of the application, next week,
we are holding a series of
events themed application week.
Where we are actually going to go into all
different facets of telling your story.
What does your story mean in
a business school application context?
What are ways to start it?
How do you put pen to paper?
How do you convey it to
people over kind of speaking?
And we also have a number of different
panels with admission officers about
the parts of the application.
How do we use it?
What are ways that you can think about
understanding who you are in our process
and how to put your best foot forward.
And if you haven't done so already,
I encourage you to start MyStanford.mba
dashboard with a few questions there.
We'll help consolidate and
put together things that might
be of most interest to you.
So with that, thank you again,
Tomar, I had [LAUGH] a lot of fun.
I can't wait to see you on campus,
hopefully in the near future.
Everybody who joined us, thank you for
sharing your time with us.
Have a great rest of your day and
stay safe.
[MUSIC]